NOW, BEFORE I ANNOUNCE THE
NOMINEES FOR BEST LIVE ACTION
SHORT, I'VE GOT A QUESTION FOR
ALL THE NOMINEES HERE.
CAN I GET A QUICK SHOW OF HANDS?
HOW MANY OF YOU STARTED OFF YOUR
CAREER WORKING AS CAST OR CREW
ON A SHORT FILM?
I'M NOTICING SOME OF THE PEOPLE
GO STRAIGHT TO THE TOP.
EXACTLY.
LOOK, YOU CAN ALWAYS BE SURE THE
CATEGORY FOR BEST LIVE ACTION
SHORT WILL SHOWCASE SOME OF
TOMORROW'S GREAT FILMMAKERS.
AND YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHY.
BUILDING A WORLD, DRAWING AN
AUDIENCE INTO IT, TAKING THEM
ON AN UNFORGETTABLE RIDE
OVER AN HOUR OR TWO IS
DIFFICULT ENOUGH
TO DO IT IN UNDER 20 MINUTES
IS A MIRACLE.
IF FEATURE FILMS ARE NOVELS,
SHORT FILMS ARE LIKE POEMS.
THEY HAVE LESS SPACE TO WORK
WITH, BUT THE DISTILLED VISION
THEY CONTAIN, CAN OFTEN
MAKE EVEN MORE OF AN IMPACT.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR BEST
LIVE ACTION SHORT FILM.
“FEELING THROUGH,” DOUG ROLAND
AND SUSAN RUZENSKI.
[ APPLAUSE ]
“THE LETTER ROOM,” ELVIRA LIND
AND SOFIA SONDERVAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
“THE PRESENT,” FARAH NABULSI AND
OSSAMA BAWARDI.
[ APPLAUSE ]
“TWO DISTANT STRANGERS,” TRAVON
FREE AND MARTIN DESMOND ROE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
“WHITE EYE,” TOMER SHUSHAN AND
SHIRA HOCHMAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
“TWO DISTANT STRANGERS, TRAVON
FREE AND MARTIN DESMOND ROE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
OH, MY GOD.
OH, GOD IS SO GOOD.
TODAY, THE POLICE WILL KILL
THREE PEOPLE.
AND TOMORROW, THE POLICE WILL
KILL THREE PEOPLE.
AND THE DAY AFTER THAT, THE
POLICE WILL KILL THREE PEOPLE.
BECAUSE ON AVERAGE, THE POLICE
IN AMERICA EVERY DAY KILL THREE PEOPLE.
WHICH AMOUNTS TO ABOUT
1,000 PEOPLE A YEAR.
AND THOSE PEOPLE HAPPEN TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY
BE BLACK PEOPLE.
AND, YOU KNOW,
JAMES BALDWIN ONCE SAID
THE MOST DESPICABLE THING
A PERSON CAN BE IS INDIFFERENT
TO OTHER PEOPLE'S PAIN.
AND SO I JUST ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE NOT BE INDIFFERENT.
PLEASE DON'T BE INDIFFERENT
TO OUR PAIN.
>> WE'D LIKE TO THANK NETFLIX
FOR GIVING OUR SHORT FILM
A CHANCE TO BE SEEN BY THE WORLD.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE ACADEMY
FOR CHAMPIONING THE
ART OF THE SHORT FILM.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK JOEY BADA$$,
ANDREW HOWARD AND ZARIA
FOR BRINGING OUR SHORT FILM TO LIFE.
AND WE'D LIKE TO THANK
LAWRENCE BENDER,
SEAN COMBS, CHRIS UETWILLER,
JESSE WILLIAMS, NICK MAYE,
VAN LATHAN, MICKEY MEYER,
JAMES SAMUELS AND NICK FREW
FOR MAKING THIS DREAM A REALITY.
>> AND I WANT TO THANK TONY,
MY MOM, AND ZARIA,
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, BABY.
I LOVE YOU.
>> AND I'D LIKE TO THANK CHELSEA,
MY MUM, AND MY BROTHER.
LOVE YOU, TOO.
THANK YOU ALL.